III want to do uh something else now
very quickly related to the whole
Hillary fainting at the 911 memorial
situation and then I'm basically going
to consider this over and done with
until uh if and until we get uh Hillary
Clinton's medical records which she says
she's going to release we did the bigger
analysis of where the Clinton campaign
miss stepped on the handling of the
Hillary fainting incident uh in New York
City over the weekend I want to address
one other really specific issue that has
been kind of blowing up since last night
last night Hillary Clinton went on CNN's
Anderson Cooper show and while she was
speaking to Anderson Cooper she said she
had had these incidents where she either
felt faint or fainted a few times okay
I'm going to play the clip for you here
uh people's heads are exploding over
what Hillary Clinton said here let's
take a look together and then discuss it
let me ask you your husband said tonight
in an interview with Charlie Rose and he
said quote rarely on more than one
occasion over the last many many years
the same sort of things happen to her
meaning you when she got severely
dehydrated can you say how many times
over the course of the last say five
years you've been to hydrate and gotten
dizzy I know you passed out hit your
head back in 2012 which led to the
concussion how often has this happened
oh I think really only twice that I can
recall uh you know it is something that
has occurred a few times over the course
of my life and I'm aware of it and
usually can avoid it yeah this is not
objectively a health concern I mean it's
just not some are saying well she's
fainting because she's hiding the fact
that she has Parkinson's oh well that's
completely unproven speculation right
but objectively speaking just fainting
is not necessarily a health concern I
admit I've fainted a few times in my
life when I tell people about it they
say really well did you get checked out
and the answer is of course yes and it
has not been knock on wood or lucite uh
it has not been connected to any broader
health issue
some people have this tendency right
when I was in sixth grade I got up very
quickly to go to the bathroom in the
middle of the night fainted ended up
with a huge bruise on my chin my teacher
I could tell was really thinking I was
getting beaten up at home because who
believes that oh I just fainted going to
the bathroom in the middle of the night
but I did that's really what happened
got checked out doctor said just have to
sit on the side of the bed for uh you
know 30 seconds before standing up when
I was in eighth grade I had a fever flu
like symptoms I was clearly doing too
much because I didn't want to be just
sitting around uh sick and I fainted
same thing again and I remember being in
10th or 11th grade a similar incident
where I got up very quickly to go to the
bathroom in the middle of the night
these are called vasovagal incidents and
I fainted there I really take care not
to do that at night and the scariest one
I had was actually five years ago four
or five years ago I don't know that I've
ever mentioned this on a flight to
lisbon in portugal i I actually fainted
twice on the plane and this it was a
completely insane situation i woke up
sort of in the middle of the night and
relatively short flight from the east
coast to lisbon uh and i wasn't feeling
quite right and I I got up and I went to
the back of the plane and asked for some
water and I came back and sat down I I
had this like undefinable sense of not
feeling quite right and I remember uh
just in an instant basically waking back
up and feeling that feeling of not
really having fallen asleep but just
there's like a gap in time and my
girlfriend who was sitting next to me
said it was basically three to five
seconds and uh it immediately happened
again just after that never figured out
what caused it went to the doctor when I
got back said maybe it was uh something
you know some the food that was served
that caused a weird reaction ran all
sorts of tests long story short not
determined to be connected to any
broader health issue so is this about
presenting my medical records to the
audience absolutely not but what I am
doing is just telling you a story to
make the point that fainting in and of
itself is not indicative of any
particular condition
and we will ultimately see what Hilary
Clinton releases this week but the
people freaking out Hillary Clinton
remembers fainting or feeling faint a
few times what does that tell us about
anything it tells us absolutely nothing
I've talked about how people of all ages
but particularly Millennials are owning
cars less and participating more in the
sharing economy and one of the more
popular options is zip car which gets
you a car when you want it when you need
it they offer all sorts of cars SUVs
hybrids whatever you need it includes
insurance and it includes gas you just
pay for the time that you actually use
the car and you can reserve the car
online from your smartphone over the
phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1,600 pounds per year for our
audience zipcar is offering $25 a free
driving credit if you sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com / David support our show
reduce your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at join zipcar
dot-com / David